new explosion of cases in the
coronavirus crisis if you heard this the
u.s reported a record-shattering number
of new infections
just yesterday more than 144 thousand
nearly 1900 people died
now that is the most in a single day
since may long lines have formed across
the country as people are hoping to get
tested and cases are on the rise in at
least 47 states
no states currently meet the cdc
guidelines for reopening
but many remain at least partially open
as officials struggle to balance
economic worries
with saving lives david begneau is in
south bend indiana for us home to the
university of notre dame david good
morning to you health experts are
concerned
about students bringing the virus home
for thanksgiving so what's the plan
there
well here's the deal they're telling
their students if you want to leave
campus you have to get tested or else
we're not going to allow you to come
back next spring
we've been in the midwest all week we
started in michigan went to ohio now
we're in indiana
the governor here had imposed
restrictions then he rolled back just
about all
all restrictions in september and now
he's imposing restrictions again
the ap says hospitalizations in the
state of indiana are up they have jumped
200 percent
the coronavirus pandemic continues to
accelerate
at a record-shattering pace as the white
house remains silent
governors are taking action reimposing
restrictions and urging residents
to get back to the basics governors like
indiana republican eric holcomb
i'll sign an executive order that will
implement pandemic requirements for
all hoosiers his neighbor to the east
ohio republican governor mike dewine
warned that businesses could be forced
to close if
infections continue to spike it's
advancing quickly
and seeking victims in every community
in ohio
if you don't know any of its victims yet
sadly i suspect you will to new york now
governor andrew cuomo who is a democrat
announced new restrictions on private
gatherings
limiting them to 10 people and placing a
curfew on bars gyms
and even some restaurants and it is
scenes like this
students rushing the field after notre
dame upset clemson last saturday
that have renewed concern about spread
on college campuses
ashton weber who is a junior was at the
game but she did not rush the field
she says other students who were at the
game have started testing positive
now the university is mandating that all
students get tested
before they go home so we are all
receiving
exit time before we leave and if we do
not get exit tested then there will be
holds placed on our registration so that
we can't
get ready for classes to come back for
next semester
other universities have announced
similar plans for mandatory
exit testing and are not bringing back
students
until next year that's the plan at
indiana university
according to university president
michael mcrobbie we realized that was
that was going to be extremely dangerous
because uh everybody leaving coming back
there was bound to be
a massive spike of uh the virus when
they when they got back
so we will do um extremely robust
testing for students
when they leave the campus when they
come back into the campus
you know the cdc is urging all americans
to limit thanksgiving gatherings to
people
in the household and they specifically
said that college students
should not be considered members of the
household given the current climate
situation so
if your college student is coming home
for thanksgiving it's best to stay
away but if they're going to come home
mask on
six feet away social distance and keep
the windows open gil
yeah that's a very good point very good
advice thank you david